since president Ferdinand Marcos Jr took
office seven months ago there has been a
succession of high-level U.S visits to
Manila on Thursday it was defense
secretary Lloyd Austin's turn I have
always said that it seems uh to me that
the the future of the Philippines and
for that matter there is a Pacific we'll
always have to involve the United States
walking to talk the Marcus
Administration has granted the U.S
military access to four more sites
meaning American troops will now be able
to operate in nine locations but Austin
has clarified there will be no permanent
U.S basis
and it also provides us the ability to
respond effectively to
humanitarian
issues and also disaster relief and
other types of crisis
one of the bigger and long-standing
crisis is the territorial dispute
between Manila and Beijing in the South
China Sea although an international
ruling in 2016 invalidated China's vast
claims the Asian giant has built
artificial islands and continues to
encroach on Philippine Waters
that and China's threat to take Taiwan
by force have critics fearing a bigger
U.S military presence will serve more as
an irritant rather than a deterrent we
think that this move by the United
States and Philippine governments will
further escalate tensions in the west
Philippine Sea in the South China Sea as
well as in the area region of Taiwan and
we do not want the Philippines to be
part of that conflict
former president Rodrigo duterte wanted
to scrap the agreement that allows joint
military drills between the Philippines
and the us but under his successor the
largest balikitan war games involving 16
000 soldiers are planned for April the
United States and the Philippines
military Alliance may have been through
a few Rocky years but the Philippine
government under President Marcos has
put all that behind one could say it's
an old partnership in a new era partner
below Al Jazeera Manila
Gregory polling's director of Southeast
Asia program at the center for strategic
and International Studies he's joining
us in Skype from Washington D.C good to
have you with us on R Jazeera we heard
Lloyd Austin saying there that there
weren't going to be any permanent bases
even though the U.S troops would have
access to all these uh additional ones
does this in any way change any sort of
Power Balance within the region
yes and no I mean sector off is
absolutely right this agreement doesn't
allow permanent U.S basing these are
Philippine facilities the model here is
more like what the Americans are doing
in Australia rotating through Australian
facilities it doesn't radically alter
the balance of power in say a Taiwan
contingency but it will seriously Aid
the U.S Philippine Alliance particularly
in the South China Sea where the
distances to U.S Basin in Japan and Guam
are just prohibitive the the Americans
if they're going to defend Filipinos at
Sea need to be closer to the action we
heard in barnabillo's report there one
of the protesters against this move
saying that there was a risk that this
could escalate tension How likely is
that do you think
I say the tensions have been escalating
just fine
um without this I mean when we only look
at this from the perspective of China we
rob the Philippines of its own agency
what we should be asking is what has
Beijing done over the last several years
to make successive Philippine
administrations so scared that they see
no option but to deepen the alliance
with the Americans
over the last couple of years the nature
of the interactions that we've seen
between China and the Philippines have
been
um of a somewhat non-military scale if I
can put it like that it's not been big
attacks or bigger assaults it's been
um Chinese a Navy for example pushing
Philippine fishermen off reefs where
they've been fishing it's been tough at
that level in what way does this help to
address that if indeed it actually does
so the biggest thing it's going to do in
the short term is uh help with Patrol
and surveillance capabilities so the
Filipinos can keep an eye on their own
Waters and Aid the modernization efforts
of the Philippine military because the
way the China plans to take the South
China Sea is not with a big show of
force it's by slowly shoving the
Filipinos and other Southeast Asians out
and the Americans can help maintain some
degree of access
how is China going to react to this
because of course China also has
bilateral agreements in terms of trade
and certainly investment in the
Philippines
that's right so the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs spokesperson already issued a
statement of course saying that this is
terrible and part of the U.S containment
policy that of course is a bit like the
boy who cried wolf everything the US
does in Asia is part of a containment
pain in the eyes of Beijing at this
point I don't think it will
fundamentally change anything about
beijing's approach to the Philippines
though because China has pursued the
exact same coercive approach in the
South China Sea across now three
Philippine administrations both Pro and
anti-American so it doesn't seem like
the manila's behavior actually has any
impact on the way China kicks the
Philippines around really interesting
get your thoughts on this Gregory
Pauling thank you very much indeed for
your time
thank you